okay i'll ask you guys would you guys
date a girl would you marry a girl
mother of your children
who has done corn
i want you to go first
come on please listen
i agree with um
both of what you're saying to be honest
but i follow more so
what pearl's saying we all have choices
like you can be from
a poor background and still be
successful you could choose
a life that's
makes you a bad quote-unquote bad
citizen
or you can
choose bad citizens that's a strong word
very bad
listen you could be a criminal you could
you could but what is okay criminal and
sex work is super different yes
think about it you don't have to be a
sex worker you there's so many things
but but exactly what you think about sex
work think about it your body if you
think about it your body we're talking
about we're talking about
soul ties right now
giving yourself to multiple people here
and there you don't think you're getting
soul ties from that but but in what way
are you talking about physically or just
over like uh
it's different with
physically and then emotionally as well
you can give yourself to someone
physically but you never gave them to
emotion it's quite different in my
opinion okay also let's talk about the
fact that this whole world of of only
fans and whatnot was
the consumers are men
it's not women it's men and women have
been over sexualized throughout their
life and
have been you know structuralize
ourselves uh i'm sorry
that's not true because no it's not no
it's not because we grow up in a society
that that tells you
like men will want you if you are a
certain type of way right so like
okay like sex work women wouldn't do
that if men weren't like that that's
them capitalizing on the entire both
sides but at least but we have a backup
plan like if a man is broke he's broken
homeless like
you don't see them like coming also
the whole met this world is run by
privileged white men women didn't
couldn't even vote until what i don't
even know
why don't we bring it i and i agree
but what is that awesome because it's
getting too political
your followers are going to be here what
does it mean
yes
we're talking about
this it's getting too political and uh
so i'm gonna shut up now you're welcome
i'm gonna shut up
you sure yeah no shut up
don't worry i'll pick you back up i feel
like okay what were you a bit of a
compound to be honest
i feel like it's a bit of cardboard like
you still have to make your choices by
yourself you don't have to do you don't
have to do certain things that you don't
want to do so even though
quote unquote men
sexualized woman this and that there's a
lot of smart women who know this
and use it to their advantages to get in
spaces
where they can gain resources resources
to boss upon these men
you don't have to you know no that's
fact that's bad yeah how you're saying
it's like you're saying that they have
no choice no i'm saying that let's not
judge women that are brought to that
point that's what i'm saying no one
brings you to a point
you have a choice everything in life is
a choice
okay
and i'm talking for the women who feel
like they haven't had a choice in that
situation so you're talking about
everything life is a choice but there
are genuinely women who throughout their
life have not been shown how to value
themselves other than their sexuality
right their body that is their commodity
so if that is their way of surviving in
a very harsh world for a lot of people a
lot of women specifically and that's how
they provide then who's to judge
that's and
again
let me shut up but it's not it's not
judging to say i wouldn't marry that
person that's your own people yeah
that's what i'm saying like i think men
have a right to be selective in who they
date
and marry yeah and so i don't think that
like we're entitled to their
understanding
you know what i mean like i think
that
like there's a difference between saying
i wouldn't date that person and you know
saying you're a terrible person because
that's what you had to do i feel like
there's also a difference though like
for example
i have someone in my family who started
doing sex work
only fans because she wanted some extra
money but she didn't need it yeah she
had a place to live that's i feel like
that is a different situation my opinion
on that is completely different rather
than someone who literally is just
trying to survive right i just think you
can't pay for my own
[Music]
okay wait pause for a second um that's
what i was about to say um thank you for
the super chat in the comments um pearl
you got the facts and we back you up she
is talking crazy sorry because your
whole following is
anti-feminism
why cause you stick up for what's right
and what's right to me
and that's what i'm looking for
is opinion based it's fine yeah my
opinions are very strong that's why i
shouldn't be on this type of platform
they love you though
they love you they hate love you
is a choice men can't like if they're
five five what are they supposed to do
yes fires doing a lot of short men
are rude because they have short man
syndrome
that's just that it's true
i don't think a sharp man can handle you
no i know that they can because i've had
one before
there's only one one but it's only the
one that's the only one i've allowed
she said
so you like
like big tall strong man
concrete jungle
do you see me i'm a big [ __ ] like yes
yes
not suitable for children
she wants to strength
oh my god okay okay
okay second question do you guys believe
in soul ties yes or no
define the soul ties for god
a soul mate is like the one person
you're supposed to end up with that's
like right for you a soul tie is like
when you sleep with someone you're like
connected to them in some way
because it's kind of interesting because
birth control just changed the whole
dating game so much because people used
to get married so much younger like like
now the average age of first marriage in
the uk is 31 in the for women and like
32 for men and in the u.s it's like 28
for women 29 for men where before they
used to get married like younger i feel
like it's also because women are more
independent now and have more financial
capability to take care of themselves
for sure
for sure but that's why well that's what
i'm saying like before you know people
would wait till they were married
because they get married at like 17 to
like 20 right but now people are almost
30
so they have like a whole decade of
sleeping around go ahead just ask a
question respectfully yeah
i forgot there was a show on netflix
last year around uh
christmas time and basically
it was showing that when